with negotiations over a new coronavirus
relief package collapsing in congress
this week
president trump signed executive
measures at his new jersey golf club
today
it's all in an effort to bypass
democratic lawmakers
cbs news correspondent michael george
reports now from new york
president trump signed executive orders
saturday aimed at providing economic
relief for millions of americans
my administration has been working
around the clock
in good faith to reach an agreement with
democrats
on additional china virus relief
the president's move comes after
negotiations with congress over a new
relief package
hit a wall whether the president has the
legal standing to act on his own
remains unclear his actions are designed
to defer
evictions payroll taxes and student loan
payments
and extend enhanced unemployment
benefits at 400 dollars a week
democrats are seeking to extend the 600
dollars a week that expired over a week
ago
on capitol hill administration officials
and democratic lawmakers couldn't reach
a compromise on the overall price tag
for a new relief bill
what they want is a two and a half
trillion dollar
blank check come back when you when you
are ready to give us a higher number
they want to bail out states
that have been badly managed by
democrats badly run by democrats for
many years
more than 30 million americans are
receiving unemployment benefits as the
coronavirus pandemic batters businesses
across the nation
in early april mary benedetto was laid
off from her job cleaning lounges at the
san francisco international airport the
six hundred dollars
you know the federal fund it really
helped me
you know i could pay off my bills but
given a choice
benedetto says she would go back to work
because she loved her job
michael george cbs news the president
also said he would be working on cuts in
income tax and taxes on capital gains